foreign
dear Marie what's up Dallas I'm sorry
what's up Marina you're good
um I was hoping to get a conversation
template from you for uh me and my mom
excellent what's going on
okay so it's codependency and investment
um so normally when you hear about these
you hear about it as like the kid living
in the Mama's basement
um this is actually kind of the opposite
so when I was in my mid-20s you started
asking for a little bit of money
um a couple years later she was down for
a year for medical stuff
um and during that year she ended up I
ended up paying half her bills and then
after that progressively it's just
gotten worse
um and the more that I enabled her I
thought you know oh this it'll just help
her get you know a break and then she'll
get back up she never got back up and so
exactly made everything worse and worse
and now we're at this point where like
she still has medical stuff going on but
she's also refusing to stand up and try
and live her life anymore and so I made
a conversation where I can like I don't
I don't want to go for a throat and be
like dude you know this isn't okay
because that never helps anything but at
the same time like I need a way to tell
her hey like I get to have my own life
you don't you you can't just take over
you know so one I appreciate your heart
man thanks for loving your mom and I
know it's gotten sideways and out of
control but
um that's a great impulse good for you
good for you thank you
um and also thank you for loving future
Marie enough to go whoa this is about
I'm about to dig a hole that I can't get
out of
um and you've done something that is
really rare
most of the time I have to start this
conversation by telling people to stop
blaming and that's not what you're doing
the way you framed this whole thing is I
kept doing and I kept doing and I kept
doing and I want to learn what I can do
next it's different
what an incred you're incredible that's
awesome oh thank you awesome
and any outcome is going to suck just
know that going in
there's nothing there is no magic
conversation where your mom's gonna go
oh my gosh you're right I'm so sorry and
then she just gets up and goes and gets
a job
so yeah I want you to figure out there
was no magic yeah put to bed that this
ends with you and your mom like like
Waltzing through a field of somewhere
right and there's just like snow coming
down like that's not gonna happen
um right so what do you what's the
what's the best case scenario for you
um I would love for her to go get
counseling
counselor just pay like a portion or all
of her bills and to stop
giving me more and more because right
now what it feels like is she's slowly
handing me portions of her life and
making me responsible for them and then
she hates her life okay well I I can't
do anything for that like you're your
own person you have to take control of
your own life except you're taking
you're taking those things that she
hands you
right and and
then I'm like she's having medical
issues and stuff like that so I feel
like I can't responsibly say I won't
necessarily take it if you if you
actually have a problem but at the same
time like I don't want to take things
that you don't actually need me to be
taking you know right
um I think you're gonna have to change
your language a little bit because her
definition of what she needs and your
definition of what she needs are going
to be different
so I think you getting out of her head
you getting out of what you think she
needs at a time
is is going to be important and you are
going to have to focus on here's what I
can provide
and here's what I'm willing to provide
and
some of those the can and will those are
messy
those are messy because you can have
money in the bank and your mom's like
but you can just do it and you're saying
yeah but I'm not going to
because I've decided that I'm gonna use
that money in a different way and that
is a hard hard conversation so
does she have the ability to pay her
bills or is she choosing not to go to
work she have money in account somewhere
how what's this Gap
um she doesn't have a whole lot of money
in the account
um
she just quit her job
um she was a truck driver we were both
truck drivers she went down
um from a medical reason and then she
was this is the second time in two years
she's gone down for medical so she said
she didn't want to come back to truck
driving so now she's job hunting
so is she living with you
yes the first part of it is
well when you say medical issues
um
give me a little more context
originally several years ago she went
down for a blood clot in her leg and
that's when this whole process actually
started and got really you know I
started paying more of my bills two
years ago she actually started um I she
was in Fort Worth Texas she had been
doing a run she was making 400 a week I
was making around 600 a week
um and she started having issues with
her bills and when I told her I'll give
you a little bit more but no more than
this amount
um she's but a month later she was in
the hospital for audible hallucinations
and then they got her sorted within a
week when she went to the hospital and
then two years later you know she had
gotten cleared to come back out well
around him two months ago she went off
the truck again because she was she was
saying she was feeling weird and she was
having a hard time focusing and and all
this and so then she went back into the
hospital and now she's leveling back out
again so but it's interesting timing
because it's like whenever I hold that
boundary I'm on I'm on Dave Ramsey's
baby steps too and so I told her I'm not
going to be helping with you know some
of the money stuff and so it's like
almost as soon as I set a boundary
there's
some things here and I can't say it's
not something serious because she does
go into the hospital but at the same
time the timing is really interesting
sure
um I yeah hospitalization doesn't isn't
a benchmark for how serious or not
serious something is they'll if you show
up they'll take you and they'll put you
on an IV and they'll put you on meds is
she getting is she getting
needed medication when she's there and
it levels her out and she comes back out
and doesn't take her meds
yes she took the original meds for a
little while and then she stopped taking
them
um but she was fine so she stopped
taking them after a couple weeks but
then she was fine for a year and a half
until I told her you know hey I'm doing
this thing and also in a year I want to
get off the truck and go like to school
okay and that's something so there's a
couple of ways you can do this one one
is easier than the other okay okay
um and I'm sure people will write in on
YouTube comments or on the podcast
comments with their thoughts of what you
should be doing you can read those at
your peril
um there may be some good stuff in there
sometimes there's some good stuff
sometimes there's just a bunch of
harrowing awful stuff
um
step number one is I want you to focus
on where you want to be in three to five
six years
and I want you to reverse engineer that
plan that just means I want you to start
five years from now how old are you now
32. okay so 37 year old Marie where is
she working where does she live how much
money does she make
okay and then I want you to back that up
with all the way to tomorrow
what do you need to do starting tomorrow
to get there so if you want to go to
college and become a nurse
that's going to be a four-year degree
plus some training you would need to go
get registered for classes summer
session two right and so you're going to
start doing things now they're going to
get you there whatever it happens to be
that you want to do so that's step one
step two is be realistic with where you
are right now what are your finances
what's your debt situation what is your
living situation and be very realistic
about what you can afford and what you
cannot afford
Okay the third thing is is then you
begin to sit down with Mom and say
here's what I will and cannot do
now a very difficult pickle you're in is
evicting your mom
if you say if you're going to continue
to live here you've got to pay rent
and you've got to pick up the light bill
that's fair
that means you can't just sit at home
and you're not getting back on the truck
that's fine that means you've got to go
get another job that's not going to be
fun and pleasant but you're
participating in this household
the obvious answer is or what are you
gonna evict your mom and put it on the
street probably not
right the other option is you move or
you say in six months I'm getting a new
apartment I'm going to go to this
particular school I'm getting out of the
truck I'm going to this college I've
saved up enough money to to not take on
any student debt I'm gonna go do this
thing but you come up with a plan where
you vacate your home that where you live
now
okay um
she would be left
then she she's got six months we feel
bad for her you're gonna feel bad either
way
okay
and you've heard me say this but at some
point you're gonna have to choose guilt
over resentment because if this
continues you're gonna hate your mom
and we do not want to go there no
so you'd much rather feel guilty that
your mom is mad at you
then
every time I go to my own home and my
mother is there
she is completely abandoned any sort of
life that she wants to live and it's
misery
and I hate it you don't want to go there
okay and so I mean there's not a lot of
good options you're gonna feel bad
you're gonna feel weird either way you
go
would this work better if I got
I got family counselor or something like
that to mediate
will she even go
um she's said she doesn't sound excited
about it but she's a
music I really wanted to here's the
thing and it's your money
and so usually it's in reverse a parent
will call and say hey I'm paying for my
kids college I'm really worried about
them they seem more anxious so they seem
more depressed what I'll tell them is
you tell them as a benefit of receiving
my money
you have to go see a counselor
it's your money
and so your mom can make a choice of
either she doesn't get your help or she
takes care of herself
and I think it's important to call out
this feels really weird mom because I
feel like I'm acting like your parent
and in some ways I am and I want to
switch the roles back
I need my mom
and I miss my mom
do you see the difference there
yeah it's kind of call it's it's not
kind of it's calling out the awkward I'm
a huge fan of calling out the awkward
whenever there's an awkward conversation
I had one with my son the other night
and I just said hey
this is this is gonna be weird and he's
like okay Dad here we go but I just like
to call it out that way
um not always the best strategy but
that's the one I usually use so I think
it's taking all those awkward weird
things and just putting them out this
conversation is going to be hard this
conversation is going to be weird I am
running into a math problem I can't
support us both and eventually get me
out of the truck so that I can be
healthy and financially secure over the
Long Haul no pun intended like I it's
not working so I have to make some
different choices and I know that now my
choices are going to affect you so that
means you are going to have to make some
different choices whether you want to or
not
here's our option here's your options
and that's where you already having your
plan I am going to go to nursing school
I am going to go to Roofing school I
don't know what you want to do HVAC or
whatever whatever you want to do I am
going to go do these things
and so I'm not asking mom for your
permission or what do you think or I'm
not asking that I'm telling you what I'm
gonna go do and here's how that is going
to affect you and here's the choices you
have you can continue to pay rent and
that's going to allow you to stay here
you can go see a counselor with me
because that's a part of me allowing you
to stay here or I'm moving in six months
to a one bedroom apartment in North
Carolina because that's where I'm going
to school whatever whatever it is you
want to do
um but again the template as you asked
for is you find you figure out what your
path is
number two you figure out the
mathematical realities of where you live
what it costs to be you and what it's
going to take to get you to this
to this destination
and then three be very dog I mean very
clear not dogmatic but be very clear
with your mom here's the challenges
here's the awkwardness here's the
challenges here's your two paths or
three paths that you get to choose
in any sort of well I'm just not oh you
don't love your mom expect that to
happen that's gonna be how she rolls
because that's how she's rolled for the
last several years
and I'm gonna be compassionate and
treated with respect and dignity
she doesn't want to be where she is
either
she doesn't want to be feeling more and
more depressed and more and more
helpless and more and more like she
can't take care of herself and her own
kid has to take care of her
which then feeds the shame cycle which
then feeds the cycle of I'm not doing
anything and this whole thing just gets
worse and worse and worse so it just
takes the adult and the relationship
which is you right now to say I'm I'm
hitting the stop button on this we're
controlled deleting this thing
so hopefully that helps let me know how
those conversations go and if she wants
to call in I'd love to talk to her too
or if y'all both want to call in uh that
might be an interesting show and um
however I can help you as you head off
into this new Direction I just want to
tell you again how proud of you I am
you're going into this with the right
heart and the right spirit that you are
the only person you can change can't
change mom
can't change mom's thoughts you can't
change their actions you can just change
yours and yours will affect yours but
you are looking in the mirror first and
I love it